مساء الخير
اولا تهنئه دوله قطر على التنظيم الممتاز
لبطوله كاس العالم التي حققت نجاح المدويا
للدوله وكذلك للمنطقه برمتها منطقه الخليج
في صوره عامه
بين فرنسا وقطر واردنا ان نناقش مع كافه
الجهاد ولسامه
سمو امير دوله قطر
كل هذه القطاعات نرى احتمالا وفرصا للمزيد
من تعزيز العلاقات الاقتصاديه
شكل وكوبون
الجميع اننا نقف امام مناعطف في تاريخ
الطاقه العالمي في اوروبا كنا معتمدين
اكثر من اللازم على الموارد ان النفطيه
والغازيه من روسيا راينا انه مع الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا
في دول اوروبيه وبالتالي الخيار الذي نريد
الاستمرار به مع رئيس الجمهوريه وخيار
الاستقلاليه
الطاقه المتجدده وكذلك على المفاعلات
النوويه تعرفنا ان فرنسا من كبرى الدول
النوويه في العالم والاستقلاليه ايضا تعني
تعزيز التعاون مع دول
تربيتنا بها علاقات وديه وماتنا مثل دوله
قطر من اجل ان توالي دانه
الغاز الطبيعي المثال وبالتالي التعاون
بين تروى فرنسا
مبنيون على علاقه متينه من الضروري ان
نضمن لمواطنين هذا الاستقلال في مجال
الطاقه في مجال الانتاج الوطني ولكن ايضا
من خلال
تعاون متين طويلاجل بين قطر وفرنسا حول
الغاز الطبيعي المثال
طلب الفرنسي والجرى الاتفاق على تزويد قطر
فرنسا بالغاز الطبيعي الموساد
من قبل دوله قطر وانا ممتلئ لسمو امير
دوله قطر
الماليه وعدد من الفاعل من الجهات في قطر
وراينا انه بالنسبه الى توفير الغاز
الطبيعيه المثال الرد كان ايجابيا ايضا
هناك نقاشات الايجابيه
تعزيز بين دولهتين
سنعمل في الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله على
تحديدي القطاعات والجوانب الخاصه بهذا
الاسمرات ولكن
الانطلاقه جيده وهي تتماشى مع خيارات رئيس
الجمهوريه الفرنسيه وكذلك سمو الامير قطر
وهو يتماشى مع مصالح الدولتين
حرب اوكرانيا لكن هذه الحرب تضغط في اكثر
من مجال على فرنسا وعلى دول اوروبيه اخرى
تحديدا في الجانب الاقتصادي والمالي نتيجه
المساعدات وزخم المساعدات المستمر من
اوروبا ومن بينها فرنسا لاوكرانيا الى اي
مدى تستطيع فرنسا الاستمرار بالالتزام
بالدعم العسكري والمادي لاوكرانيا مع ما
تشهد من همم غضب شعبيه على ما اللت اليه
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في البلاد
سمكه شو دي في السودان
كافه الدول الاوروبيه التي وحدت
الصفر
له دوله اوكرانيا
من دوله اخرى هي روسيا بدون اي مبرر بدون
اي سبب
اوكرانيا الى انتهاك سيادتك اراضيها نحن
في اوروبا في فرنسا نحن دوله حقوق الانسان
ونحن لدينا قيام وما بدا نؤمن بها سياده
الدوله
ليس امرا يمكن ان نتراجع عنه بالتالي نحن
ندعم اوكرانيا طبعا لهذا ولكننا سنستمر
بذلك فلما ان هذا ضروري كان رئيس
الجمهوريه الفرنسيه واضحه حول الموضوع
اوكرانا بحاجه الى دعمنا سندعمها كذلك انا
ارى ان الاقتصاد الفرنسيه يقاوم حين ارى
الارقام ايجابيه بالنسبه الى فرص العمل
تتحسن انظر الى الاستثمارات من قبل دوله
قطر دروع الاخرى هي في تزايد في فرنسا لان
فرنسا صارت اكثر دوله جذب الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه في اوروبا
كما يحصل في فرنسا لان فرنسا هي من الدول
التي هي الاكثر نجاح اقتصاديا في اوروبا
لا يمكن اخفاء هذا الغضب الشعبي لما التي
اليه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه كان في فرنسا او
في باقي الدول همم
الاوروبيه
ويتمظهر هذا الغضب الشعبي
شيئا فشيئا تظاهرات
كيف تتعامل فرنسا مع هذا الغضب الشعبي وهل
بامكانها تلبيه المطالب المرفوعه في اثناء
هذه التظاهرات لا سيما ما شاهدناه مؤخرا
اشكرك يشيطون الزنك يوتيوب
هذه المخاوف
مرتبطه بظاهره عرفناها في كافه اسقاعي
العالم الا وهي التضخم ترتفع اسعار الغاز
والكهرباء والنفط وكذلك المواد الغذائيه
هذا كله يثير الكثير من القلق والمخاوف
وهذه المخاوف هذا القلق تعزز بسبب الازمه
في اوكرانيا ولكنها اصلا التضخم كان موجود
قبل سمعته اكرانيا
اوكرانيا مما عزازه ارتفاع الاسعار
في فرنسا مع رئيس الدوله لقد اعتمدنا
خيانه استراتيجيا حمايه الاسره الفرنسيه
وكذلك الشركات ضد ارتفاع الاسعار لقد
وضعنا نظام كمان للطاقه لحمايه مواطنين من
ارتفاع اسعار الغاز والكهرباء وبالتالي
كان مستوى التضخم وعدم تضخم في فرنسا هو
فعلا الادنى في كافه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهذا هو نجاح رئيس موريال ماكرون الذي تم
انا المخاوف كذلك هناك نقطه قلق اخرى له
علاقه باصلاح نظام التقاعد لدينا ولكن يجب
علينا انه فسيره ونقنع المواطنين ان هذا
النظام الاسلاح هو لحمايه
فرنسا لكي يكون من يعمل
لم يعد يعمل
نظام التقاعد هو جزء من المشكله وليس كل
المشكله ما دامت المؤشرات في فرنسا كما
تقول هي همم مؤشرات ايجابيه واا الاداء
الفرنسي كما تقول هو من افضل همم الاداءات
في في
اوروبا اذا ما الذي يمنع من تلبيه مطالب
المعترضين والمحتاجين بشكل مستمر في فرنسا
اذا كانت اذا كان الوضع مبشرا الى هذا
الحد
مي
في فرنسا هو جيد جدا في اوروبا الارقام
تظهر ذلك نحن نتحدث عن كل الاصلاحات التي
نفذناها منذ بدايه الرئيس
عن سياسه جيده للشركات
وكذلك
دائما الاصلاحات في مجال التقاعد تثير
المخاوف حين نطلب من المواطنين القيام
ببعض دائما
يخافون يقلقون يقولون لقد عملته لفتره
طويله من حياتي اريد ان اتوقف اريد ان
اتقاعد لا اريد ان استمر بالعمل
طبيعيه ويجب ان يعالج هذه المخاوف وهذا ما
نقوم به مع رئيس الجمهوريه مع الوزاراء
ولكن اص نظام التقاعد سوف يعتمد والدوله
الفرنسيه سوف تعمل بطريقه اكثر واحدهتان
على امل ان نحقق المزيد من النجاح
الاقتصادي باختصار وسؤال اخير سيد الوزير
عندما اشرت الى همم الدعم الفرنسي
لاوكرانيا شملت الدول الاوروبيه هل كل
الدول الاوروبيه بنفس مستوى
الحماس للاستمرار في الدعم العسكري
والمادي والاقتصادي لاوكرانيا باختصار
فيديو في نيويورك
ضعيفه جدا
وغير موحده الصفوه بالتالي سوف لن تتحرك
هو قد اخطاؤه لقد اخطا في حساباته لقد
توحدت اوروبا
من هذا النزاع في اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا